bonjour messieurs merci d'être avec nous
sur rt français denis millet qu'elle ait
fait de l'extension du passani terre
dans les pharmacies en termes de
demandes de vaccination de réalisation
de tests de dépistage
alors il ya ton test de vitesse j'ai une
augmentation massive depuis l'annnonce
de maquereaux évidemment ce qu'il
continue ça s'atténue un petit peu mais
pas beaucoup par contre au niveau
vaccination il ya eu effectivement un
pic très important de demandes si
maintenant plutôt en train de diminuer
un petit peu on encore des gens qui
viennent qui demande qui sont intéressés
par la création et le pitch a eu au tout
début après l'annoncé au simple on a
toujours quelques personnes qui
effectivement s'y intéresse même si
elles sont pas on sent qu'on vaccine des
gens un peu à contrecoeur qui viennent
disent bouron je suis un peu obligé ou
de par mon métier ou parce que j'ai
envie de sortir et donc ils viennent un
peu à contrecoeur donc on a besoin
d'être plus rassurant quand leur fait
les vaccins à ce moment-là côté francis
pas longue vie cela fait maintenant une
vingtaine de jours que les commerçants
restaurateurs elles sont tenus de
contrôler le pas salutaire de leurs
clients quels bilans est ce que vous
tirez alors il ya un bilan mitigé les
très petites affaires de la restauration
les bars les cafés sont quand même
particulièrement affectées ça leur
enlève du chiffre d'affaires ça peut
aller jusqu'à -40 % du chiffre
d'affaires donc
incontestablement le tas sanitaire
appliquée d'une manière généralisée
sur les terrasses des cafés les
restaurants qui ont des terrasses
sont obligés de demander le tass sacré
quand même un trouble économique par
rapport à ses acteurs et ce n'est pas
toujours et forcément cohérent parce que
quand on va faire ses achats dans une
grande surface commerciale on ne vous
demande pas pour autant le pas le tass
sanitaire vaccine vaccination ou test
donc c'est quand même un problème et ça
crée une tension vous vous souvenez
quand même que pendant plus d'un an les
commerçants ont subi les répercussions
de gilet jaune et après des grèves
contre les retraites donc les
commerçants sont quand même inquiet le
gouvernement
donne l'impression nous assure que s'il
y a des pertes de chiffre d'affaires
elles seront compensées et je pense que
c'est une nécessité absolue il faut
absolument pas retiré catégoriquement
les aides peut être pas d'une manière
aussi généralisée que par le passé mais
il ya quand même un problème un état
d'esprit clivant les uns contre les
autres ceux qui sont vaccinées ce qui ne
les sont ceux qui ne le sont pas et je
pense que le gouvernement ne doit pas
aller vers une obligation de la
vaccination parce que nous sommes des
êtres humains adultes conscients il ne
faut pas toujours infantiliser le peuple
le peuple s'il l'a saby qui est en jeu
peut prendre des responsabilités la
preuve année il ya plus de 50 millions
de français qui ont engagé la
vaccination est davantage si on prend ce
qui n'ont fait que la première partie
donc je pense que le gouvernement doit
être très attentif ces manifestations
quand elle faisait quand elles sont dans
l'exagération
elles nous sont elles sont
répréhensibles comme s'attaquer à un
stand d'un pharmacien ce n'est pas
tolérable mais prêts à gérer autant il
faut quand même rester dans un cadre de
démocratie car justement ce climat de
tension qui évoque francis un ballon
mais comme un style
comment est ce que vous le ressentez
dans vos officines d'éliminer alors
personnellement j'ai prêté atteint par
ce genre de phénomène mais on a des
confrères qui vient qui aurait été la
vaccination va s'il avait suivi des
menaces par courrier c'est pour faire
encore sur reçu des balles de revolver
dans leur boîte aux lettres un climat
qui est assez malsain il ya eu quelques
officines sur par led qui a été attaquée
qui ont été incendiés il ya un climat
très malsain moi je peux comprendre
qu'on soit enfin bon je comprends mal
pour sa console vaccins déjà une chose
parce que je suis un scientifique non
c'est on sait que ça marche mais bon
après les gens sont libres d'être contre
ils sont libres de manifester contre ça
mais il c'est pas pour ça qu'il faut
aller imposer aux autres de ne pas faire
le vaccin en brûlant en taguant en
cassant des vitrines de pharmacie ça
vraiment on attendait absolument
à vous reposer à s'abaisser vers les
pharmacies ça va être un jour ça va être
les restaurateurs qui accepte de devenir
le past and i ter on
sait personne la craie d'une sorte de
l'autorité de l'état trop importante
mais impose la leur donne une autre
façon disons nous on n'en veut pas donc
on interdire on met notre propre
dictature enfin c'est notre dictature
c'est un peu surprenant quoi je pense
que voilà ce qui va passer à vacciner ne
le font pas c'est leur droit bon après
ils n'ont pas le droit de faire
certaines choses actuellement si vous
voulez aller voyager en guyane d'être
obligé de faire le vaccin pour la fièvre
jaune ça a toujours été ça jamais on n'a
jamais été dans la rue à cause de ça
tous les soignants son budget qui
rentrent dans leur école de faire le
vaccin pour l'hépatite b on en a tous
les ans cette saison des prescriptions
de vaccins pour l'hépatite b pour les
jeunes qui vont entrer dans les écoles
d'infirmières de kiné etc ça a toujours
existé
là on a quelque chose qui est beaucoup
plus général qui existe voilà il faut il
faut l'accepter si on n'accepte pas on
accepte de ne pas se rendre au
restaurant au cinéma aux concerts etc
mais c'est un choix
j'aime bien l'exemple aussi delà de la
ceinture dans la voiture s'il ya des
gens qui aiment pas la ceinture ils
veulent quoi la mettre dans leur voiture
eh bien ils conduisent pas là ils
veulent pas se vacciner ils font pas
aussi des bras est-ce que vous vous
sentez aussi le devoir de faire
davantage de pédagogie pour peut-être
incité à la vaccination anti copine
oui parce que ça fait partie de notre
travail c'est vraiment cette partie
intégrante de notre travail d'expliquer
d'être posée on doit rassurer rejet
vacciner à monsieur qui était
extrêmement inquiet qui a passé un coup
de fil parce qu'il n'était pas un
faiseur c'est un moderna et il faut
avoir les bons mots pour expliquer que
tout se passe bien et il est parti avec
très stressée au monde après youtube a
pris les parties rasséréné parce que
voilà je vais expliquer on en a discuté
un bon moment voilà il faut être posée
il faut pas être dans l'effectif tout le
temps et je trouve que quand on le fait
de manière posée ça se passe plutôt bien
elle francis pas l'anglais du côté des
commerçants que vous représentez ce que
vous avez eu écho aussi de quelques
séquences de fortes tensions lorsque le
pass sanitaire est demandé aux clients
qui y entrent bon
je considérerai que c'est quand même
marginale il n'y a pas tous les jours
des incidents contre les restaurateurs
bon un restaurant c'est un lieu de vie
c'est un lieu de relations humaines
bon en plus je rappelle quelque chose et
je pense que monsieur qui représente les
pharmaciens conviendra vous souvenez que
à une époque nous ne pouvions pas testé
en france et le fait que l'on puisse
tester des citoyens un citoyen qui avant
de rentrer dans un établissement se fait
tester je pense que c'est quand même une
une réaction responsable
il ne va pas aller dans un établissement
s'il est positif pour au risque de
contaminer d'autres mais s'il est jugé
négatif pour quelle raison ne se rendre
est il pas dans un lieu et donc ce qui
ne me plaît pas beaucoup en ce qui me
concerne représentants des commerçants
et personnellement c'est que le
gouvernement envisage de faire payer des
tests eh bien je pense que dans un pays
où on a eu un manque de test un manque
de masse et on ne pouvait pas être
vaccinés à une époque je pense que ce
serait pas souhaitable de rendre encore
l'attention plus forte en faisant payer
des tests parce que ça va créer une
ségrégation sociale il ya des gens qui
ne veulent pas se faire vacciner comme
l'a dit monsieur le pharmacien ça reste
quand même un libre arbitre on ne peut
pas obliger quelqu'un à on est quand
même dans une démocratie on doit
préserver nos libertés individuelles
eh bien je pense que ça sera encore un
clivage ceux qui peuvent s'offrir se
payer le test et ceux qui ne peuvent pas
se payer le test sur ce point je vous
fait réagir il ya vraiment de la part du
gouvernement un besoin de pédagogie
intensive et les gens ceux ci doivent se
vacciner et il se vaccine tous les jours
un peu plus il ya eu des pics de
vaccination comme l'art est comme l'a
rappelé notre pharmacien donc je pense
qu'il faut rester dans une grande
expectative et une grande délicatesse
par rapport aux gouvernements et les
citoyens dans mon très rapide de nimier
je voulais réagir sur ce point du
déremboursement des tests de stage
effectivement sur un plan purement
sanitaire c'est pas une bonne nouvelle
parce que des gens ne le ferons pas et
donc bon je retrouve effectivement
ostracisés et comme vous disiez monsieur
colombie
alors après c'est une décision qui est
très politique et l'air de 10 qui dit
bon vous n'êtes pas vacciné c'est le
choix de votre choix de ne pas être
vaccinés donc quand vous nous donc nous
est en cours on rembourse plus les tests
ça peut se comprendre ce plan politique
sur le plan sanitaire c'est beaucoup
plus difficile à accepter d'accord
on aura l'occasion de reprendre ces
changements le temps merci denis millet
co président de la fédération des
syndicats pharmaceutiques de france
merci à vous francis palombie président
de la confédération des connaissances